[Musique]
je cultive une variété phénoménal de
saveurs de piments tomates courges film
verne je me rends compte que ces saveurs
l'autre injures mais je les retrouve pas
nécessairement à l'épicerie isabelle
paquet et horticultrice au jardin des
plantes utiles du jardin botanique de
montréal
elle s'est donnée pour mission de
ramener la diversité des saveurs dans
nos assiettes est que plus intéressant
aujourd'hui c'est de trouver des pumas
qui sont pas trop fort mais qui ont une
saveurs d'agrumes de fruits donc c'est
vraiment très diverses en a qui ont
vraiment une complexité aromatique le
roulé que vraiment la forme habanero
seul oeil est quand même un peu piquant
mais réellement savoure yeux tout le
côté fruité
quand on goûte aux poivrons quand vos
goûters aujourd'hui le on se dit mais
mon dieu est-ce que je peux acheter sa
l'épicerie faut que j'aille acheter
selon elle les variétés de piments qu'il
cultive peuvent toutes être récoltés
dans le sud du québec
les appels quand on regarde soudain
c'est d'une grande beauté
c'est presque un tour du monde ou si
c'est un tour du mans ont effectivement
c'est vrai que c'est très artistique
toutes les couleurs les formes truc
super oui c'est magnifique trinidad
scorpions liés l'autre est très fort
ensuite nous avons thomas avec autant de
variété il est surprenant que l'on en
trouve si peu une épicerie pense que
l'objectif c'était surtout d'avoir
d'uniformité d'avoir des piments qui se
conservent pour
pouvoir être transportés sur des longues
distances donc je pense qu'il ya eu une
période qui peut être un peu nui à cette
découverte de saveurs
je pense qu'on y est on est là dedans on
est dans un retour vers les saveurs dans
les moins forts dans les poivrons
escamillo ça on va avoir un piment qui
produit au québec puis qui vient jambes
qui vient colorer rapidement ce que ce
mot on sera dans sa manche et des
poivrons bras mais escamillo c'est un
winner celui le 1 bat nada excellence
est mon préféré un banal de piment super
facile prêter une suite qui se mange
carrément comme on mange et amateurisme
le prêter ensuite le roulettes et le
chevreuil speech quoique plus relevés
font aussi partie de ces piments favori
non un petit peu fort
je disais tout à l'heure leurs roulettes
que j'adore alors moi je voulais partir
quelque part donné un petit coup de
pouce pour essayer de faire en sorte
qu'il n'y avait plus de goût dans nos
épiceries dans nos assiettes
ça commence par vous et j'espère que ça
va faire des pluies à cheval ch'ti 1
poivron aujourd'hui au coeur de son
jardin isabelle réuni un panel pour une
dégustation d'une soixantaine de
variétés de piments
j'ai évité aujourd'hui déjà qu'ils sont
actifs qui sont impliqués dans le
maintien la recherche des savoirs dans
notre assiette
semenciers maraîchers distributeurs chef
cuisinier et restaurateur se prête à
l'exercice 63 cents ils goûteront de
nombreuses variétés de piments et de
poivrons dans l'espoir qu'à moyen terme
il soit intégrée dans l'offre
alimentaire courante
moi je mettrais 23% les poivrons en fait
c'est simplement des piments qui ont pas
de piquant on va les appeler pourra
prendre des claques à mancey un peu
piquant on va apprécier un piment doux
et précis baisse un piment fort
extra-fort le panel goûtera les piments
par ordre croissant d'intensité créé par
la capsaïcine qu'ils contiennent une
molécule qui provoque la sensation de
pick up à ma cause du sens c'est celle
là ça fait passer aussi un job on en a
fait une tonne pour martial une vraie
tonnes de lait bio dit michel lachance
fait le lien entre producteurs
maraîchers et restaurateurs il ya de
l'eau plusieurs de ces piments locke qui
sont disponibles à montréal entre autres
marchés jean talon est temps avec hector
larivée plusieurs de ces choses on les
distribue déjà
la restauration le chef portugais joao
dias est un passionné de semences et de
piments rares il en possède toute une
collection
j'adopte carcela bikinians le brésil
c'est vraiment fruits t il légèrement
doux et aussi la ricamarie de perreux
j'utilise beaucoup au restaurant lorsque
de nouveaux produits comme cela leur
sont présentés les chefs s'amuse en
réinventant leurs recettes favorites
un poulet puis ribéry avec des primes
aux oiseaux ainsi vite chez rehaussé
avec des hadjis à mario ou encore une
marinade avec des péquignot des piments
hongrois au touax et le petit
marseillais au cours des cinq dernières
années
jean-françois daou a cultivé une
centaine de variétés de piments en chant
et en serre je voudrais qu'il pousse
tout on est capable je capable de tout
les amener à maturité
le problème c'est que c'est la mise en
marché ils sont pas tout autant apprécié
qu'est-ce qui était précieux au québec
souvent ce que je remarque des piments
qui sont plus sucré puis pas tropiques à
de nombreux plats pourrait voir le jour
si tous ces piments peu connu et est
commercialisée à grande échelle
il y en a plein d'autres qui pourraient
tout à fait commercialisés et vendus
dans les grandes surfaces
ces deux trois ans j'aimerais ça que on
retrouve certaines variétés davantage
son marché de 10 variétés que je
connaissais pas que je veux faire mettre
en chanson
si cinq ou dix ans le paysage des
piments épicés niveau complètement
transports
[Musique]
e